ces dernières secondes que j'ai de
souvenirs puisque j'ai eu un blackout de
quatre joueurs entre mon accident s'est
passé ce dernier dernier obstacle est en
fait j'ai un trait sur un mur un mur
blanc face à mort dans l'accident
moi j'étais quelqu'un de très casse cou
je sais ce genre de couillon quand vous
avez des sceaux dans une rivière n'a pas
vérifié le fonds est le premier à partir
à faire des saltos avant/arrière bon
bref
[Musique]
j'ai perdu connaissance en l'air c'est
l'impression qu'avait mon petit frère
qui lui m'a vu mourir mes frères bon
humour l espèce de pantin désarticulé
puis je m'explose par terre ont une
tombé dans la descente je tombe sur le
côté dis donc une chute de près de 10 m
et voilà je me casse les deux jambes et
la colonne vertébrale est alors la
chance que j'ai si je ne tiens pas de
ces moments là donc la souffrance la
mienne celle des autres angoisse moi je
n'ai pas vraiment vu que
[Musique]
je suis en soins intensifs deux jours
après l'accident je limite les mythes
marlon brando dans le parrain et je
convoque amont je fais mes parents mes
frères l'un en leur disant tu vas aller
détruire la bosse et je parle d'un
espèce de dire est qu'ils ont un fou
rire imaginé en soins intensifs
vous avez juste des petits rideaux ça je
me suis vue de la couleur de ses rideaux
orange un peu moche qui séparent les
différents boxe avec des gens qui pour
certains s'en sortiront pas au bout de
trois semaines un matin je me réveille
et est en fait je sais pas c'est rien
tous les matins où cette fameuse grotte
du matin dont on parle souvent et là je
suis un geste sur le dos dont vous êtes
comme ça avec vos pieds au bout et là en
fait je vois plus mes pieds je me
retrouve en fait ma première réaction
bien 18 ans et donc j'ai eu cette chance
là c'est que j'ai récupéré encore et
encore de la motricité nationalité
jusqu'aux genoux
et effectivement moi j'ai une quête
frénétique notamment de me prouver de
prouver la terre entière que je pouvais
plaire je peux prendre du plaisir et
donner du plaisir ça commençait en
location avec avec matinée avec une
aide-soignante avec des infirmières avec
une patiente la sexualité des personnes
handicapées c'est un tabou et ça devrait
pas l'être et en corse par la sexualité
mais le plan tabou c'est la vie
affective des hommes handicapés avec des
femmes valide
j'en connais énormément et des femmes
handicapées avec des hommes valides
j'en connais extrêmement peu
[Musique]
là c'est en termes d'émotion en termes
reconnaissance de mon parcours sportif
mon parcours d'homme de mes engagements
c'est voilà c'est tout en haut et c'est
peut-être une si ce n'est la plus grande
émotion de ma carrière
[Musique]
voilà moi je suis là je suis vivant est
bel et bien vivant et ben tant pis si
c'est pas en mettant un pied devant
l'autre si ce n'est pas en courant le
100 m en 10 secondes et donc oui l'idée
c'est transmettre ça c'est pas un
optimisme avec je suis pas un imbécile
de leur dire vrai c'est super had an il
ya des moments pour les il ya des
moments pour tous pour la souffrance
pour le monde difficile et puis on aura
d'autres
enfin c'est la même pour tout le monde
donc nettement d'ici là qui fait ce que
fait ce qu'il faut parce que c'est fini
c'est fini donc on y va on sait plaisir
et ont joué tous ensemble de l'année